Hallelujah.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
Well, I've titled this one the greatest
invitation.
And uh this is an invitation that has
gone out to mankind
ever since the great events around
Jesus's life. In John 2 verse 19
Jesus says destroy this temple and in
three days I will raise it up. Now the
temple of course was a type
and it served nearly as a type for
everything that Jesus stood for
and uh in a sense we too can become part
of a spiritual temple which God is
preparing. And he says, "He who
overcomes, I will make a pillar in my
house, in my temple." So there's a
spiritual temple that is being prepared.
But here Jesus is talking about a temple
saying, "This temple and in three days I
will raise it up."
Well, the temple was quite magnificent.
Here's a a replica of it that was built
in miniature. And you'll find this one
in Jerusalem. And the Jews answered him
in John 2:20, "Then the Jews said, 40
and6 years was this temple in building,
and will thou rare it up in three days?"
But verse 21 tells us what it was all
about. But he spake of the temple of his
body. So Jesus was predicting that he
would die and that in three days he
would rise from the dead. Now the Jews
used inclusive reckoning. So if he died
before sunset on the Friday, that was
day one. The Sabbath he rested in the
grave.
And the first day of the week he rose
and any portion of a day was considered
a day. So that was three days. And uh he
spoke of his resurrection.
Now, if you go
to Jerusalem, you will find this garden
tomb where some claim Jesus lay. And it
looks highly probable that this is the
right place. And there's a groove here.
And uh in this groove, there must have
been a giant stone, a giant flat stone
that could be rolled away. And that's
sort of what it looked like. It's an
interesting place. They discovered this
while doing some excavations
and when they came across this they were
stunned because everything fits so
beautifully into place. Tomorrow night,
tomorrow evening, I will be giving a
lecture on uh where Jesus walked and
we'll be looking at some interesting
facts in regard to this very place.
Verse 22 says in John 2, "When therefore
he was risen from the dead, his
disciples remembered that he had said
this unto them, and they believed the
scripture and the word which Jesus had
said." John 2:22. Now, what scripture
were they referring to? Obviously, the
only scripture that there was was the
Old Testament. And so, it referred to
the Old Testament in the book of Isaiah.
There's a beautiful story of the Messiah
and how he would suffer and how he would
die and how he would be crucified
amongst criminals
and uh they must have referred to those
scriptures. John 2 verse 22
1 Corinthians 15:14
17 and 18 take this resurrection and
tells us what the significance is.
And if Christ be not risen, then is our
preaching in vain? All the other great
religions of the world
serve at the tombs of their founders.
But not Christianity. The tomb of Christ
is empty.
And so it says, if Christ is not risen,
then our preaching is in vain. And your
faith also is in vain. And if Christ be
not raised, your faith is in vain.
You are yet in your sins. Because only
through the death and the resurrection
of Christ can my sins be forgiven. And
this is something that the world must
understand
because there is this movement today to
join up all religions as if they were on
the level with each other.
But if you remove this sentence, then
salvation becomes meaningless.
Then they also which are fallen asleep
in Christ are perished. So in other
words, those that died in Christ are
waiting for the resurrection which is
guaranteed
through the death and the resurrection
of Christ. He was the first fruits of
that resurrection.
How could he be the first fruits if the
Bible says that others were raised by
Christ himself and the book of Jude
implies that Moses was raised? Well, the
fact of the matter is there are people
in heaven that never died like Elijah or
like Enoch. And uh what about them? If
Christ is the first fruits, there was
the wave offering and Christ the first
fruits rose together with the graves
that were opened and a number of people
were raised from the dead at the
resurrection of Christ.
What about all them? Christ is the
guarantor. In other words, even if
people were translated before the death
of Christ, it was under the fornowledge
that Christ would die and be raised from
the dead and overcome sin. So they their
salvation depends just as much on the
death and resurrection of Christ as ours
does.
This Jesus delivered up according to the
definite plan and fornowledge of God.
You see the fornowledge God knew that he
would succeed. Could he have failed?
>> Yes, he could have. He was fully human
and he was fully divine. But he never
used his divinity once to protect
himself. Not once. And so in his human
form, in his humanity, he could have
failed, but he succeeded where Adam
failed.
So this Jesus delivered up according to
the definite plan and fornowledge of
God. You crucified and killed by the
hands of lawless men. But God raised him
up having loosed the pangs of death.
So only in Christ is their salvation.
Amen.
>> Because it was not possible for him to
be held by it. This Jesus God raised up
and of that we are all witnesses.
Can we be witnesses today of the
resurrection of Christ? Yes or no?
>> Yes, we can. Yes, we can. Because only
in Christ do you find the type of
transformation
that we see in people who have accepted
him and follow him in all his ways.
Without him, it is impossible. So Christ
must be alive.
>> And if you walk with him and you will
have an experience with him, then you
will know that he's not rotting in some
grave, but that he is the one who rose
from the dead and sits at the right hand
of the father.
And then after the resurrection, Jesus
gives the commission.
Go ye therefore and teach all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Ghost,
the full Trinity, the full power of the
Godhead, teaching them to observe.
What does it say?
all things
whatsoever I have commanded you and lo I
am with you always even unto the end of
the world. Matthew 28:19 and 20. What a
tremendous commission. And this
commission is allencompassing. You
cannot leave out a portion here and a
portion there. You must teach
everything.
So a relationship here that culminates
in baptism is based on truth. It is
based on the word because what Christ
taught them either through the prophets
or personally is the word of God.
And uh we cannot take portions of it. We
have to take all of it. Observe all
things whatsoever I have commanded you.
Did Christ speak through the prophets in
the past? Yes or no? Absolutely. All
things were created by him and for him
and nothing was created that was not
created by him. So everything from the
beginning comes from Christ.
>> Baptism is mentioned 80 times in the New
Testament. Would you think that that was
important then?
>> I would think so. It's not just a
fleeting thing. 80 times it is
mentioned. John 3:23 says, "And John
also was baptizing," speaking about John
the Baptist in Enon near to Salem.
That's another form for Jerusalem
because there was much water there. So
for baptism, do you need a little bit of
water or do you need a fair amount of
water?
>> You need a fair amount of water. John
3:23. So what does it mean to baptize?
The Greek word is baptisto, which means
to dip, to immerse, to plunge
underwater. And there must be a specific
meaning to this as well because God does
not do anything haphazardly. Everything
that God does and says has a meaning.
has a deep spiritual meaning. God is not
a god of the just. So,
so to baptize means to put under water
and this is the Jordan River and this is
where John the Baptist baptized because
there was much water there. Matthew 3:5
and 6 says, "Then went out to him,
Jerusalem,
and all Judea and all the region about
the Jordan were baptized of him in
Jordan, confessing their sins." Now,
what is sin? We've learned about that.
What was that? Transgression of the
>> law. So people who did not live in
harmony with God came here, confessed
their sins, and the baptism was a symbol
of the washing away of sin. And they
came and they reasoned. And John the
Baptist spoke
wishy-washy words or plain and cutting
words.
>> Plain and cutting words. And then
eventually Jesus himself came to John
the Baptist. And John the Baptist knew
that Jesus was the Messiah
and he said to Jesus, "I will not
baptize you. You must baptize me. I'm
not worthy to to loosen or tie your
shoelaces."
And Jesus said, "Let it be so." Now, it
is proper for us to do this to fulfill
all righteousness. Then John consented.
Now we have a question here.
If baptism is a symbol of the washing
away of sins, one of the symbols,
was it necessary for Jesus to be
baptized?
Did he have any sin?
>> No. He says the devil is coming and he
has how much on me? Nothing. Nothing.
Not one sin. Jesus was the sinless,
spotless son of God. Why was it
necessary then to fulfill all
righteousness that Jesus
also submitted himself to the right of
baptism?
Because Jesus is not only our savior,
he's not only our God, he's also our
example.
>> And so Jesus sets an example. And it is
said in the Bible that if you follow
Christ, you should walk just as he
walked. So studying the life of Christ
is studying the Christian walk. And
Christ was baptized.
>> Amen.
>> And Jesus when he was baptized, Matthew
3:16,
he went up out of the water. What does
that tell us? How he was baptized?
>> Under water. He must have been under the
water. That's what it says. So Jesus was
under the water at that moment. Heaven
was opened and he saw the spirit of God
descending
like a dove and lighting on him. So the
spirit of God descended
not as a dove but like a dove. Now how
does a dove descend?
Gently, gently.
And a voice from heaven said, "This is
my son whom I love." That's the NIV. Or,
"This is my beloved son." King James
version. With him I am well pleased.
Matthew 3:16 and 17.
Whenever someone is baptized, that same
privilege is his or hers. Amen.
>> When you are immersed, then the same
thing happens. The Holy Spirit descends
like a dove and God says, "This is my
beloved son or daughter in whom I am
well pleased." So the dove
does not necessarily literally mean a
dove but the attributes of a dove are
what we will find in the function of the
Holy Spirit. That is something that uh
is worthy of studying.
God anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the
Holy Ghost and with power. Now the word
power there implies
the means, the mechanisms, the tools if
you like to put it bluntly and simply
to do everything that he was going to do
because he being fully human yet fully
divine was not going to use his divinity
to his own advantage. And in all things
he was tempted such as we were. So he
tapped into the same power that we can
tap into who went about doing good and
healing all that were oppressed of the
devil for God was with him. Acts 10
verse 38. So in the power of the Holy
Spirit, he went out doing good and
preaching the gospel of salvation in him
for the next three and a half years.
Now the Pharisees had heard that Jesus
made and baptized more disciples than
John. So John the Baptist wasn't the
only one who was baptizing. And in fact,
it says Jesus himself baptized not but
his disciples. But the disciples
baptized people
after John. Now the question here arises
again. Why did Jesus not baptize?
Because he's the one that is typified in
the baptism. He set as an example. But
his disciples were the ones that
baptized thereafter. John 4 1 and 2. Now
something else that's interesting about
baptism and the type of questions that
arise around baptism because today it is
believed that all you have to do is just
say here I am. I'm ready. You baptize
yourself and basically Christ paid it
all and we can live as before. But Jesus
placed people under grace and then
referred them back to obedience. Do you
remember that? We've mentioned it
before. The classical case was Mary
Magdalene.
Neither do I condemn you being placed
under grace. Go and sin no more being
placed again under the law. Now in this
particular instance, there was this uh
high official. He was the treasurer of
uh a queen. He was a unch. He was a
black man probably.
And he was traveling through the desert.
He had been to Jerusalem. So he was a
Jew. He was a devout Jew. And he was
reading the Bible, the Torah. when
Philillip was sent to him. Acts 8:26-28.
And the angel of the Lord spake unto
Philillip, saying, arise and go towards
the south unto the way that goeth down
from Jerusalem unto Gaza, which is
desert. And he arose and went. That's
also if God speaks, do it. And behold, a
man of Ethiopia, a unoch of great
authority under Candace, queen of the
Ethiopians, who had charge of all her
treasures. So he was the minister of
finance. That's what he was. But he was
a Jew because he had come to Jerusalem
for to worship. It was the Passover. And
so he came to worship on that particular
day. Was he therefore acquainted
with the rights and laws and judgments
of the Jewish system? Yes or no? Yes.
And he was a devout Jew. He had come to
worship. So he knew everything about the
Old Testament. Do you think he knew the
Ten Commandments?
Absolutely. He knew the Ten
Commandments. and he came to worship
and he was returning and sitting in his
chariot and he was reading Isaiah's the
prophets.
Acts 8:26-28.
And so, Philip comes up to him, sits,
he's invited up onto the chariot, and he
talks to him, and he says to him, "What
are you reading?" And he says, "I'm
reading Isaiah the prophet." And uh he
says to him, "Do you know what you are
reading?" And he reads a passage of
scripture and he talks about the lamb
that was taken before its sharers and
who opened not his mouth and was led to
the slaughter. And Philip asks him, "Do
you know what this is about?" And
interestingly, the uno says, "How can I
unless someone explains it to me?"
That's fascinating. God operates like
this. He works through people and he
informs people of truth via his people.
And here was a devout Jew. He was
studying the book and he was seeking to
find an answer. And Philillip was there
to supply it.
Philip ran to him and heard him read the
prophetas and said, "Understandest thou
what thou readest?"
And he said, "How can I except some man
should guide me?" Different translations
say should explain it to me. And he
desired Philillip that he would come up
and sit with him. The place of the
scripture where he read was this. He was
led as a sheep to the slaughter and like
a lamb dumb before his sharer, so opened
he not his mouth.
And so Philillip explained it to him.
What was the one thing this Jew lacked?
He had the law. He had the Torah. He
knew what it was to be obedient and to
keep God's precepts. But what didn't he
know?
He didn't know who the Messiah was. And
so Jesus was introduced to him by
Philillip. And when he realized that,
when he realized that this
sheep
was the one that was being slaughtered,
that it was the lamb of God that takes
away the sins of the world. That is when
he said to Philillip, as they traveled
along the road, they came to some water
and the unoch said, "Look, here is
water. Why shouldn't I be baptized?"
and he ordered the chariot to stop.
He knew the law. He knew the Torah. And
now he found the treasure of heaven. He
found Jesus Christ.
>> Amen.
>> The savior. And so he says, "Why should
I
shouldn't I be baptized?" Now this whole
section in the book of acts is written
in a kayastic structure which means
answer or question answer question
answer question answer. Now, if you have
an NIV Bible or if you have any of the
modern translations of the Bible, you
will be hardpressed to find this verse
because your Bible will have verse 36
and verse 38, but it'll leave out verse
37. Check it tonight if you want to.
Acts 8 verse 37.
And Philip said, the question was, what
hinders me from being baptized? And
Philip said, "If thou believest with all
thine heart, thou mayest."
Very important answer. So what was the
prerequisite
to baptism?
>> Believe in thy heart.
>> Believe with all thine heart. Why do you
think some modern translations prefer to
leave that verse out
and also say at the bottom that it was
not in the original text? But the kayazm
which is a question answer question
answer question answer would be
destroyed if you left that text out. And
so that text as it stands in the King
James version and in some good
translations
should be there.
>> Amen. And it says, if thou believe with
all thine heart, thou mayest. And he
answered and said, I believe that Jesus
Christ is the son of God. Now remember,
he was a Jew.
Jesus said, teaching them what? Do you
remember it?
>> All things whatsoever I have commanded
you. all things. If you love me, keep my
commandments. Today, we have people who
do not not know anything about the
requirements of God. And they accept
Jesus as their savior and think they can
walk on as before without coming into
harmony with the precepts of God. So,
the Jews had the law and they didn't
have the Messiah. Today, we want the
Messiah and we don't want the law. It's
rather confusing. In actual fact,
those that keep the commandments of God
and have the faith of Jesus. That is
what the Bible says is the group that
stands for the whole gospel. Because why
did Jesus die for us? Because we were in
transgression.
Does that mean we stay in transgression?
Of course not. So it's very important.
If thou believest with all thine heart,
thou mayest. And he answered and said, I
believed that Jesus is the son of God.
This is what he lacked. He didn't know
the Messiah. And when he accepted the
Messiah as his personal savior,
he was baptized. Then both Philip and
the Uno went down into the water and
Philip baptized him. Acts 8:36-38.
So in all the examples that we have we
see that the Bible talks about a baptism
and that it is a baptism of immersion.
Now if we go to the early church you
will see that the early church also
baptized by immersion. Here is a
Bzantine cross and an old Bzantine
church. And uh this one is in ruins of
course. And if you walk through these
ruins, there is an ancient baptismal
font where they baptized these people.
There's a closeup. You can see it over
there. You went down the steps and uh
that's where they baptized. So the early
church after Christ baptized by
immersion. This one over here is an
interesting one. This is also a Bzantine
church. This was built there where the
Eenes used to live. And uh these early
churches all had baptismal fonts with
steps leading down. This is in the
desert where there isn't much water, so
they had a smaller font. But baptism by
immersion is certainly possible in a
font like this. If you go to the ancient
churches, they also revealed a method
that was used in previous times. This is
the first century church in Philippi.
This was the baptismal font where people
were baptized.
And uh if you ask yourself where does
the baptism by sprinkling or by infusion
pouring the water over the forehead of
an infant comes from? Well then you have
to go to Rome to find out because this
is where it stems from. And even if you
go to some of the older churches in
Rome, you still find large baptismal
fonts.
And uh here in Capadia and Turkey, the
hidden city of some Christians in the
middle ages, there you also find
baptism by immersion. And they had these
deep baptismal fonts where you went down
the stairs and were baptized by
immersion. some of the reliefs and some
of the paintings that we have of that
early period. If we go to Russia, for
example, here's the baptism of the
Russian king Vladimir the Great. A
painting of that by the early uh
Bzantine church. Today, the Orthodox
Church is a remnant of that. Also,
baptism by immersion. And here's an
early relief of uh Christ being baptized
by in an African fresco. And there you
have also him standing under the water
and he's the water coming up to his
waist. So where does this infant baptism
then come from? If the Bible speaks
about baptism by immersion and if the
Bible says if you believe with your
whole heart then you may
can an infant believe with his whole
heart. Can an infant make a decision?
Yes or no?
>> Who makes the decision for the infant?
>> The parents make the decision for the
infant. And the infant that cannot make
up its mind yet, that doesn't have the
capacity to understand is covered by the
parents. The New Testament says, Paul
says that if you have a marriage and
just one of the individuals
is in Christ,
then the husband is sanctified by the
faith of the wife or the wife is
sanctified by the father.
Or else what does it say? Your children
would be unclean.
Fascinating text. In other words, when
we look at infants and small children,
the responsibility
for their nurturing and for their growth
and for their final capacity to make a
decision by themselves rests with the
parents. And Jesus did what to little
children.
He blessed them. He said, "Suffer not
the little children to come unto me."
and he blessed them and he for
reprimanded his disciples when they
tried to keep the infants away from
them. But this infant baptism is not
biblical. It comes from an ancient
right. It comes from Babylon
because infants were dedicated via this
system in the past. They even took
infants some rights and immersed the
whole infant. But uh most of them
actually just infused or sprinkled.
In the 6th century AD,
we have the introduction of infant
baptism. Now, the god Yanos, who was the
two-headed one, the one that looks
forward and backwards. We have the same
in the two-headed eagle. That's where it
comes from, was twice born. Holy water
was used for baptism and it was made by
taking a torch from the altar and
plunging it into water which then became
holy water.
And uh today it is the same sort of
thing. They take a candle in some writes
from the altar, plunge it into the water
and it symbolizes the sun god plunging
into the waters of the womb to be reborn
as Horus the savior.
So that's where this ritual comes from
and where holy water comes from.
The following curse was pronounced on
Roman Catholic Church defectors.
May the Son who suffered for us curse
him. May the Holy Spirit who suffered
for us in baptism curse him. Let him be
accursed who says adults must be
baptized. This is history of Romanism
page 510.
So Rome introduced
infant baptism to come into harmony with
the ancient pagan rights. Now by the way
you can see where this actually comes
from because in the pagan right the holy
spirit and horus are all one entity. You
know the dove was the symbol of the
female aspect of the deity. So if you
look at Luciferian worship then Lucifer
is both male female you know and the
dove and he is also regarded as the Holy
Spirit that we read in Alice A. Bailey's
books. And what is interesting here is
that it says because they are all one.
May the Holy Spirit
who suffered for us in baptism curse
him.
Did the Holy Spirit suffer in baptism in
the Bible? Yes or no?
>> No. The Holy Spirit descended gently
like a dove on Jesus. Who was the one
who was going to suffer and die?
Jesus was going to suffer and die. And
certainly
the baptism that took place does not
reflect this baptism but reflects the
plunging and the death of the son god
but not of Jesus Christ. So the curse by
Roman Catholicism that you are cursed if
you
stand for adult baptism tells us where
it comes from.
Cardinal James Gibbon, the faith of our
fathers, answers this question or
answered that question for several
centuries after the establishment of
Christianity.
Baptism was conferred by immersion. So
the Rome admits it that total immersion
was the way in which baptism took place.
But since the 12th century, the practice
of baptizing by infusion, that's pouring
the water over the forehead, has
prevailed in the Catholic Church, as
this manner is attended with less
inconvenience than baptism by immersion.
Does that make much sense?
>> That doesn't make much sense at all.
John 3:3 says, "Verily, verily, I say
unto thee, except a man be born again,
he cannot see the kingdom of heaven.
So this born again
represents a dying and a resurrection
and baptism stands for that death and
that resurrection
one that we experience in Christ.
It was not until the council of Ravena
in 1,311
AD that sprinkling and pouring were
officially accepted as equally valid as
immersion in the right of baptism. So
the pagan rights were brought in gently,
gently, gently and today they are there.
They are entrenched and if you don't
follow them then you are accursed.
So like with all the strange doctrines
that we have in the Christian world
today, we have to go to Rome to find
them. This system where church and state
works together to bring about one
unitarian form of religion
which will be the ultimate worship of
the angel with a torch, the fallen one,
Lucifer.
Well, Rome is very impressive, very
spectacular.
This is the statue of Moses that was
made by Michelangelo, and it has a
little notch in the knee. And uh they
tell us that Michelangelo looked at the
statue and said it was perfect. And then
he threw his chisel at it and said, "Get
up." But of course, it didn't get up.
just got a kink in the in the knee.
That's the story whether it's true or
whether it's not. The great Pontifax
Maximus, the great bridgeuer to take the
place of Jesus Christ, the one who is
the bridge between heaven and earth, is
certainly not the Pontifax Maximus, but
is Jesus Christ. So with all these
systems we find that Rome is the one
that is behind it and it's the one
that's receiving the accolades and the
worship today. It is claimed that infant
baptism
brings the infant into the family of God
and uh then they claim that this is the
new covenant which covers the whole
family.
Baptism is as a consequence of accepting
Jesus Christ as your personal savior,
learning all the precepts of Christ,
accepting them, realizing that we are
sinners living in transgression to God's
law and that our only hope is to have
this blood washed away in the blood of
the lamb and then walking in harmony
with Christ in his power through him.
That's what it's all about. And infants
just cannot do that. Here's a little
infant font that you will find in the
Vatican. There is no room for any
immersion in that. The Bible says in
Ephesians 4:5,
one Lord, one faith, one baptism. How
many baptisms do we have out there in
the world?
>> Many. many many different rights of
baptism.
Some baptize by immersion. The Baptists,
for example, baptist by immersion.
Others practice infant baptism by
sprinkling. Others practice infant
baptism by infusion.
Others practice no baptism at all with
water, but claim just a spiritual
baptism.
Some practice baptism in immer by
immersion by dunking once. Some practice
bapt baptism by immersion by dunking
three times in the name of the father,
the son, and the holy spirit.
And some practice baptism by immersion
seven times.
Which one of those is right?
The Bible says there's one Lord, one
faith, one baptism. Surely it should be
quite simple to resolve the issue. You
have to go to the reference source.
Isn't that right?
>> And what is the reference source?
>> The Bible.
Then why don't people
take the standard of the Bible, follow
the dictates of the Bible, and then we
should have one baptism. Isn't that
right? How many times does it say did
Jesus go under the water? Once. Does it
say anywhere that the uno went under a
couple of times? Yes or no? No.
So, it should be possible to have one
right. In fact,
any doctrine in the Bible should be
discerned by following the same method.
If A says this way is the way and that
one says no this one and this one says
no that one and the churches are
splitting all the time on these issues.
Surely we should be able to go to the
word of God and say, "Well, that's what
the word says. Let's do it that way."
And if you can find a church that says,
"This is what the word says. Let's do it
in every single aspect."
Well, then you would have one Lord, one
faith, one baptism. But unfortunately,
we don't live in a world like that.
So let's have a look at the symbolism of
baptism so we can see what it really
entails. 1 Peter 3 21. And this water
symbolizes baptism that now saves you
also not by the removal of dirt from the
body but by the pledge of a good
conscience towards God. It saves you by
the resurrection of Jesus Christ.
>> Amen.
So when you are baptized, what are you
remembering?
>> The resurrection of Christ. Now the
Christian world out there says we
remember the resurrection of Christ by
doing what? By keeping what?
>> By keeping Sunday. That's not biblical.
That's not biblical. You remember the
resurrection of Jesus Christ by
participating
in baptism. And you know what
the Bible tells us? Something
interesting. It says you are baptized,
you rise, and you are baptized in
Christ. Did Jesus also institute a mini
baptism
to remind us of this event? Yes.
He introduced
footwashing
and he said,
"As often have you do this, then do this
in memory of me. Do what I tell you. You
will be blessed if you do this. The foot
washing is a mini baptism reminding us
of
the washing of rebirth that we had. In a
sense, you are going through life and uh
picking up a little bit of dust here and
a little bit of dust there. And in the
solemn right of communion, when you
participate in the body and the blood of
Christ, then the footwashing forms part
of that. And the Bible clearly says that
we should do this. Blessed are you if
you do this and very few do that either.
I tell you the truth, unless a man is
born of water and spirit, he cannot
enter the kingdom of God. John 3:5. Will
the man on the cross, the thief,
be in heaven one day? Yes or no?
>> Yes. Was he baptized?
>> No. Then how can this text be true?
You see, if you do not have an
opportunity to do it, God will judge the
intent of the heart.
If you know and you do it not, says the
Bible, then it be for you sin. The time
of ignorance, God winks at must take all
these things into account. I tell you
the truth, unless a man is born of
water, if you have the ability and you
know, he must be born of water and the
spirit. Without the spirit, it is
meaningless. He cannot enter the kingdom
of God. This is serious. John 3:5.
So if we read on what happened in that
early church when those conversions
started taking place, they were struck
by the words of the disciples after they
had crucified Christ. And they said,
"Brothers, what shall we do?"
And Peter replied, "Repent." What does
that mean?
>> Turn around. You were going this way and
go the other way. You were in sin and
transgression. Turn the other way and be
baptized every one of you in the name of
Jesus Christ. Acts 2:37
and 38. In other words, the issue at
stake was that Jesus was the Messiah,
the one whom they crucified. They broke
the law by crucifying Christ because it
says, "Thou shalt not kill. Thou shalt
not murder. And they did it. So they had
to repent. They had to accept Jesus
Christ as their personal savior. And
they had to be baptized.
Acts 2:38 and 39. Repent and be baptized
every one of you in the name of Jesus
Christ for the forgiveness of sins.
And you will receive the gift of the
Holy Spirit, the promises for you and
your children. and for all who are far
off, for all whom the Lord our God will
call. Now, some claim this text to say
it's fine to baptize little children.
It's not what it says. It says that when
you accept Christ, then you will be
blessed according to the Old Testament
for thousands of generations. God takes
heed of your decision and you give God
the right to intercede in your life and
to stand in the hedge
and you will receive the gift of the
Holy Spirit. So when you are baptized
you are endowed with a special gift.
Before that you are prompted by the Holy
Spirit. You can be led by the Holy
Spirit. But now at your baptism you
receive a gift of the Holy Spirit. And
this promise is for you and your
children because your children are
covered by your decision and your faith
and for all who are far off all people
and for all whom the Lord will call. So
it goes into all time. 1 Samuel 15:22
says to obey is better than sacrifice.
So if God says this and if God says that
we should repent and be baptized then
that is the right thing to do.
Ephesians 4:113 says, "And he gave some
apostles,
some prophets, some evangelists, some
pastors and teachers for the perfecting
of the saints, for the work of the
ministry, for the edifying of the body
of Christ, till we all come into the
unity of the faith and of the knowledge
of the son of God unto a perfect man
unto the measure of the statue of the
fullness of Christ." So what are these
gifts for that God is going to impart
during baptism?
For the ministry. For the ministry. It
is for the perfecting of the saints. For
the edifying of the body of Christ.
Everybody receives a part. And even the
most humble person receives a part. Even
those that have virtually
no real magnificent
abilities can be so blessed by God that
they become powers and giants within the
church.
Some have the capacity to pray. Some
have different gifts. Some have gifts of
hospitality for that matter. Who's more
important?
The one who makes someone feel at home
and comfortable and comforts people or
the one who speaks the gospel? Who's
more important?
>> The one is not more important than the
other. Can the one say to the other, "I
have no need of thee." Barnabas was
known for his gentle spirit and for
making people feel comfortable.
And that is just as important as any
great gift or to be a uh evangelist or a
pastor or a teacher. Whatever the gift
is, God gives to each according as he
wills for the edifying of the body of
Christ till we all come into unity of
the faith. Now, this tells us again that
what we see out there in the world
cannot be right. You cannot have a
thousand faiths or 2,000 or more.
There's one faith, one God, one faith,
one baptism until we all come into this
harmony.
For as we have many members in one body
and all members have not the same
office,
so we being many are one body in Christ.
Now the body of Christ is the church,
the members of the body. Now can we be
part and parcel of different bodies that
teach different things? Yes or no?
Well, what do you say? If there's one
truth, one baptism, one faith, can we
have different faiths and different
teachings on issues that are purely not
biblical when we check them in the
Bible? Yes or no? No. Surely we must
come into harmony when it comes to the
things of faith.
So we being many are one body in Christ
and everyone members of one another.
So it talks about unity in the spirit
having then gifts differing according to
the grace that is given to us. Romans
6:4-6. So God during baptism when you
become part of the body of Christ, you
get endowed with the spirit and
empowered to do whatever it is God chose
you to do within the body.
And we are his witnesses of these things
and so also is the Holy Ghost. Now
listen carefully. Acts 5:32,
whom God has given to them that what's
it say there? Obey him. So, does
everybody receive this gift of the Holy
Spirit? Yes or no? No. You have to be
obedient to the precepts of Christ.
Otherwise, this text
cannot apply. You have to be obedient to
the precepts of Christ. So in other
words, the unoch was obedient to the
precepts of the scriptures, but he knew
not who the Messiah was. Today, if we
accept Christ as our personal savior, we
also have to learn how to obey him. Yes
or no?
>> You have to have both. And this is a
very important issue. This will be a
deciding factor at the end of time.
Don't you know that all of us who were
baptized into Christ Jesus were baptized
into his death?
We were therefore buried with him
through baptism into death. Does that
imply dying? Yes or no?
Yes, it implies dying. And therefore
when you go under the water you stop
breathing and that symbolizes
the death. But if it remains purely a
symbol, well then it's no real baptism
at all. If I die the death of the old
man and I rise the same old man, is that
a genuine baptism?
>> No. So if I'm not taught the precepts of
Christ, if I'm not taught how to come
back into harmony with Christ, then that
death and resurrection
is really quite meaningless. I have to
know how to come into harmony with
Christ. Don't you know that all of us
who were baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death? We were
therefore buried with him through
baptism into death. Now, do you know
that the Muslim world accuses
Christianity of being a crutch religion
because all you have to do is go on your
knees and say, "Well, Lord, forgive me."
And then you get up and you can do it
again. and you can go to uh let's say if
you're a Roman Catholic, you can go to
the priest and you can confess the sin
and it's gone. And then you can do it
again and go back and confess it, do it
again, go back and confess it and you
always have recourse to this confession.
And then if you are uh in sin, when you
die, you get the lost anointing even
when you're dead and all that stuff is
cleared away. That's not Christianity.
That's paganism.
And it's not true. Muslims say that if
you commit something wrong, you pay the
price right there. So if you're a thief,
no more hand. You lose it. You're a
thief twice. Well, then it's hard to
steal. You don't have any hands left in
some of these countries. So you pay for
what you have done. And therefore, that
is true
payment for transgression. Christianity
is a crux religion, they say, and false
Christianity is because people misuse
the grace of Christ as an excuse to
carry on a lifestyle that they had
before. Isn't that right?
But true Christianity
requires the death penalty to such an
extent that you die and are buried with
him through baptism
into death. In order that just as Christ
was raised from the dead through the
glory of the father, we too may live a
what does it say there? New life. New
life. I cannot live the old life. Romans
6:3 and4 I have to be transformed.
So when I
receive the knowledge of the son of God
who died for me and I am taught all
things whatsoever he has commanded
and I accept that I am in transgression
to God's law and I accept the gift of
salvation in Jesus Christ and I am
baptized buried with Christ in baptism.
So when Jesus died, potentially
all mankind
died with him.
>> And when he rose, potentially all
mankind
rose with him. But God honors our
freedom of choice. And when we choose to
follow him, we enact that ritual of
dying in Christ and rising in Christ and
we receive
a new life
reborn. And unless we receive this new
life, we are not saved. We have to come
into harmony with Christ. And Christ
kept his father's commandments. Yes or
no?
>> So must we keep them?
>> Yes. So obedience is a prerequisite.
People don't want that today. They want
cheap grace. They say all I need to do
is believe
and I am saved. Yes, you have to
believe. But if there is no obedience,
then you are a transgressor of God's
law. And if you break one, you break
them.
>> Oh, and you will be judged by the
>> law. And you won't have an intercessor.
Jesus says
to those that say, "But Lord, Lord, did
we not in that day do this and that and
the other and cast out demons and do
whatever it takes?" Jesus says to them,
"Depart from ye me ye that work." And
then he uses the word anomia
which literally means against the law of
God. Today in the world out there you
have a doctrine which is called
anomianism
which means doing away with the law of
God. Anomia
you cannot have one without the other.
You can't have salvation in Christ and
then not come back into harmony with
what he died for you.
Why he died for you to save you.
So in order that we live this new life,
we must be reborn. I'll tell you
something. If you really become a
Christian and you really
follow Christ in all his ways and you
are baptized and you rise in Christ and
in him through him you walk the life of
Christ,
nobody will recognize you. Your old
friends will say, "Who are you? I do not
know you. I don't want to be with you
anymore. Go away. I guarantee it. I lost
all my old friends when I became
baptized. When I started walking
with the Lord and coming back into
harmony with his precepts, all my
friends were gone. I didn't want to
drink with him anymore. I was a spoil
sport in a sense because I didn't want
to do the things I did before and uh my
old own family didn't recognize me
anymore.
So that is the type of new life that you
must lead. But thank God there are many
many friends that you make and there's a
new family.
So death to our old sinful way of life
that's very important otherwise it is
not the real thing. The burial of our
sins in the watery grave of baptism and
a resurrection to a new life in Christ.
one that is in harmony with the precepts
of Christ. 2 Corinthians 5:17,
"Therefore, if any man be in Christ, he
is a new creature, totally new, totally
new. Old things are passed away, behold,
all things are become new, totally
different. Can it cause turmoil in a
home if one accepts and the other one
doesn't?"
The old husband doesn't recognize you.
The the wife doesn't recognize the
husband. Who are you? I don't know you.
You're so different. You've totally
changed what's happened. And many times
they don't want to know you.
And only prayer and patience and
kindness can deal with an issue like
that. Knowing this, that our old man is
crucified with him. that the body of
sin, transgression of the law, that's
the definition. That's the only one in
the Bible,
might be destroyed, that henceforth we
should not serve sin. It's very clear.
Romans 6:6. So Jesus paid it all.
There's nothing I can do. Nobody can
keep the law of God. In any case, it's
impossible. Is that biblical? Yes or no?
Well, is it biblical or no? No. We must
not serve sin. Can I do it in my own
strength?
>> No. Only in Christ.
But I can stop stealing.
I can stop lying. I can stop cheating.
I can stop looking where I shouldn't
look. Because I have power over this
neck, don't I?
Likewise, reckon ye also yourselves to
be dead indeed unto sin.
If you want to be dead to sin, must you
know what sin is?
>> Yes. By the law is the knowledge of sin,
says the Bible. So if I want to be dead
to sin, must I know the law? Yes or no?
>> Yes. So you see today we have a totally
different problem to what the unoch had.
He knew the law but he didn't know
Christ. Today we know Christ but we
don't know the
>> law. And so we have to come into the
fullness of the stature of Christ.
So dead indeed unto sin but alive unto
God through Jesus Christ our Lord. So we
die with Christ in the right of baptism
are raised a new person spanking new
shining new. Now new if you have a new
car how many dents does that have when
you buy it?
In fact if you get take your brand new
car
into commission and you see a little
scratch there. What do you say to the
salesman?
Hey, what's that after 20 years driving
with a thing? Who cares, you know, about
that scratch? But you're very fussy
about your new car, right? Well, that's
what it's like. It's spanking new. How
many faults may there be in that car?
What happens if you drive down the road?
What's the matter here, right? Isn't it
supposed to be new? New means new.
totally new person. How many dents, how
many sins, how many whatever is in that
new individual?
>> Not one. They're all gone. You stand
before God as though you had
>> never sinned.
I am crucified with Christ.
Nevertheless,
I live.
I died,
but I'm alive.
Yet not I, but Christ liveth in me. So
if I boast and say I have the power to
do this now, and I have the power to do
that now, that's not biblical either. In
Christ and the life which I now live in
the flesh, I live by the faith of the
son of God who loved me and gave himself
for me. Galatians 2 verse 20.
>> It's fantastic. It's fantastic. I don't
become a puppet of Christ. Christ
doesn't control me like a puppet and
say, "You're a marionette. You have to
do whatever this and that and the
other." No, I have freedom of choice.
And I choose to follow Christ. And every
single day, the devil will say to me,
"Why are you doing that? Are you crazy?
Look what I have to offer you." But he's
got a pile of potach. He's got nothing.
And so I choose day by day to follow
Christ. So baptism commemorates Christ's
death, burial, and resurrection. That's
what it does. Secondly,
it symbolizes the death and the burial
of the old man of sin. Thirdly, it
represents the resurrection to newness
of life in Christ Jesus.
And fourthly, it indicates the washing
away of sin. Acts 22:16.
That's what the right of baptism stands
for. That is the symbolism.
When you are raised,
what happened to Jesus? The dove
descended. So when you are raised a new
person in Christ, then you receive the
gift of the spirit, whatever it is, as
God wills. You know many sit in the
church wondering
what their gift is. I don't have any
gift.
Nothing happened to me that I can
remember. If you are not willing to walk
with Christ, will you experience him?
Yes or no?
>> Many exercise their gift all their years
all the years and don't even know that
they're exercising a gift.
Whoever believes and is baptized will be
saved. Mark 16:16. This text is so
misused today. Believes means
everything. You've got to believe
everything. If thou believest with all
thine heart, thou mayest. Acts 8:37.
Brothers, what shall we do? Peter
replied, repent. That means come back
into harmony with the precepts of Christ
and be baptized. Wash away. be reborn
every one of you in the name of Jesus
Christ because only in him do we move
and have our being and do we live.
Then they that gladly received his word
were baptized. Does that mean there were
some that did not gladly receive his
word? Sure. Many didn't. And the same
day there were added unto them about
3,000 souls. Acts 2:41.
So to the body of Christ, there was
added 3,000 souls. Now today, this is a
mass baptism in the Jordan. Many people
go to the Jordan to be baptized.
Thousands upon thousands upon thousands
go to be baptized. And I wonder whether
they understand the fullness of the
right of baptism. It's nice to be
baptized by immersion because that's a
biblical way. And in fact, the Seventh
Day Adventist Church accepts the baptism
by immersion by other churches if it was
done in this biblical way. And you can
become a member by uh proclaiming faith.
Here's a young girl being baptized in a
lake. And uh you know they say the
Catholic Church said that it was less
inconvenient to do it that way. Well,
Christ said it and I was stunned by this
person. Uh I took this picture in
Germany where this young lady was
baptized. What do you see there?
>> Ice floating around. Wow.
Wow. That's determination to be
baptized. Wouldn't you agree
>> that's determination?
Let's have a look at the steps to
salvation and we'll look at them
biblically. Number one, you have to
accept. You have to accept the sacrifice
of Christ. You have to believe that he's
the way, the truth, and the life. And
you have to believe that this is the way
it is done. Number three, you must
confess. You must confess. And there
must be a decision. Revelations 3:20. We
must have all four these components.
Romans 3:23 says, "For
all have sinned and come short of the
glory of God." Everyone is sin has is a
sinner. Therefore, everyone must be born
again in order to enter the kingdom of
heaven. You must be a new person, one
that's back in harmony because you won't
enter heaven otherwise.
So, you must be born again. All have
sinned.
Acts 16:31.
And they said, believe
on the Lord Jesus Christ, and thou shalt
be saved, and thy house. The faith
covers the children. Wonderful. All have
sinned. I must accept it. And I must
believe in the merits of Christ. And I
must confess my sins. If we confess our
sins, he's faithful and just to forgive
us our sins. So if I have a baptism
without a confession, is it valid? No.
And to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. 1 John 1:9.
And behold, I stand at the door and
knock. If any man hear my voice and open
the door, I will come into him and will
suck with him and he with me. Revelation
3:20. This is what I love about the
character of God. He doesn't force
anyone. What does he do? He stands at
the door and knocks. He doesn't force
his way in. So, what must you do in the
final analysis?
You must accept the invitation. You must
open the door and invite him into your
life.
Now, we know what it stands for. Does it
also mean that I become part of Christ's
church when I'm baptized?
For by one spirit are we all baptized.
Not 10 spirits,
not 20, not a thousand, not 2,000, one
spirit. We are all baptized into how
many bodies?
>> One body. Whether we be Jews or
Gentiles. Now remember the word Jews was
used for the early Christians as well.
They were regarded still as Jews or
Gentiles.
Whether we be bond or free and have been
all made to drink into one spirit.
There's only one one truth. There aren't
10 truths, thousands of truths. 1
Corinthians 12:13.
So the Lord added to the church
daily such as should be saved. Acts
2:47. So when you accept
the right of baptism, when you accept
Jesus as your personal savior, when you
are baptized, you become part of the
body of Christ. And that body of Christ
must be the one that teaches how many
things? All things. For by one spirit
are we all baptized into how many
bodies? one body and he is the head of
the body, the church. Colossians 1:18.
Yes. So, baptism by immersion is
personal, but it is also corporate. It
means you become part of the body of
Christ.
Now, what about rebaptism?
If you have been baptized,
let's say you've been baptized in a way
that is not in accordance with the
entire biblical principle. What then is
rebaptism called for? Well, let's read
what happened in Acts 19:1-5.
Paul having passed through the upper
coasts came to Ephesus and finding
Satan's disciples, he said unto them,
"Have you received the Holy Ghost since
you believe?"
So they had accept Christ. They were
believers.
And they said unto him, "We have not so
much as heard whether there be any Holy
Ghost." And he said unto them, "Unto
what then were you baptized?"
And they said, "Unto John's baptism."
Now John preached the baptism of
>> repentance.
But the baptism in Christ implies
becoming part of the body of Christ and
receiving the gift empowering you to
preach Christ. Then said Paul, John very
verily baptized with the baptism of
repentance, saying unto the people that
they should believe on him who should
come after him,
that is on Christ Jesus. When they heard
this, they were baptized in the name of
the Lord Jesus. Acts 191
to5. Now again some denominations will
say well that means we must only baptize
in the name of the Lord Jesus. But the
Lord Jesus himself said baptize them in
the name of the father, the son, and the
holy spirit. This is the messianic
portion. Yes, you have to realize who
the messiah is. But when you are
baptized, you are baptized into the
fullness of the Godhead.
You're not just baptized
proportionally or portion a portion of
it. Without Christ, there is no
salvation. But Christ and the father are
what?
>> One. You can't be baptized into the one
without being baptized into the other.
It's impossible.
So baptism by
immersion, rebaptism is called for. If
you feel that you've had a total
biblical baptism, then as I've said, the
Seventh Day Adventist Church
acknowledges that and you become part of
the body that keeps the commandments of
God and has the testimony of Jesus by a
profession of faith. But if you feel
that it is better to be baptized into
the full truth then baptism rebaptism is
not unbiblical.
So God works through his church. This is
very very important.
Acts 9:6
is one of the greatest disciples of
Christ. And he trembling and astonished
says,"Lord, what wil thou have me to
do?" This is Paul himself. Paul on the
road to Damascus has a vision and he
sees Jesus Christ and he realizes he's
in transgression. He's persecuting
Christ by persecuting his followers. And
he repents and he says, "What wil thou
have me do?" And the Lord says to him,
you know, Paul, I've called you to be an
apostle to the Gentiles, and I want you
to go to all the parts of the world and
preach the gospel of Jesus Christ.
Nothing like that happened. Not even to
the mighty Paul. This is what happened.
And the Lord said unto him, "Arise, and
go into the city, and it shall be told
thee what thou must do." Isn't that
fascinating?
God does not work outside
his body.
He leads people. He nurtures people. But
in the final analysis, he will lead them
to the body. And Ananas went his way and
entered into the house. There was the
disciple that God chose
of the brethren to tell Paul what he had
to do. And putting his hands on him, he
said, "Brother Saul, the Lord, even
Jesus that appeared unto thee in the
way, as thou camest, has sent me that
thou might receive thy sight and be
filled with the Holy Ghost." Acts 9
verse 17. It's a very important text.
God does not raise up people outside to
go and tell the body what to do. He
sends them to the body to be told what
to do. Does that make sense?
So these are very important biblical
principles whereby one can find solidity
in one's faith. Here is the patience of
the saints. Here are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. Revelation 14:12.
So at the end of time, God would see to
it that there would be a body that not
only preaches baptism by immersion and
salvation in Christ and Christ alone,
but teaches all things, even the
precepts of Christ. And as Christ set an
example in all things, so they have to
set an example of in all things. If
Christ said, "I've set you an example in
footwashing," then you must do it, then
that denomination must do footwashing.
If Christ said, "Baptism by immersion,"
then that denomination must do baptism
by immersion. If Christ said, "If you
love me, keep my commandments," then
that denomination must keep the
commandments. Is that right or wrong?
Every single thing must be in harmony
with the word. And if it's not, then
it's problematic.
the three angels messages.
There's only one denomination in the
world that preaches the three angels
messages. There is no other. You can
search through this earth from north to
south, east to west. There's only one
denomination, one Christian denomination
that teaches the three angels messages.
and other sheep I have which are not of
this fold. Them also must I bring and
they shall hear my voice and there shall
be one fold and one shepherd. John
10:16.
God is going to bring the whole world to
a decision. Very soon this whole world
will have to make a decision. Nowhere in
all these lectures have I ever said that
if you are not a member of the Seventh
Day Adventist Church, you are lost. In
fact, I've said God's people are in
>> church,
>> all churches.
But God is going to call everyone to
reckoning. And he's going to say,
"Choose mark of the beast or the mark of
God. One of the two. Be sealed with a
seal
from the world or be sealed with a seal
of God." And we did a big study on what
that entails. The seal of God, the
Sabbath, is a symbol of obedience
to the lawgiver in all aspects.
And the sheep
will have to listen either one way or
the other. Neither prayer for these
alone, but for them also which shall
believe on me through their word. So
preaching the word is part of the gospel
of salvation. that they all may be one
as thou Father art in me and I in thee
that they also may be one in us
that the world may believe that thou has
sent me. John 17:201
he says I do not pray for the world. I
pray for those
that are willing here to obey.
Now, I know that we've been through a
lot together,
and as it was in the days of old, so
will it be in our day.
But I'm not discouraged.
You know, we've seen numbers decline and
decline and decline, and that's normal.
When you preach the fullness of
obedience in Christ and accepting Jesus
Christ as your personal savior, that's
not as po as popular as preaching
something which is
less troublesome.
And so one has this idea that this is a
hard teaching. This is a hard teaching.
Do I really have to change my life? Do I
really have to die? Does the old man of
sin really have to be buried? Can't I
just keep a little of him? Can I just be
a little bit in transgression? Do I
really have to come into harmony with
all the precepts of the decalogue? Can I
not just continue keeping Sunday, for
example? Is it not possible? This is a
hard teaching. You know, it requires a
lot. Yes, it does. It requires a lot.
John 6:60.
Many therefore of his disciples when
they had heard this said, "This is a
hard saying. Who can hear it?" Nothing
old, nothing new there. John 6:66. From
that time many of his disciples went
back and walked no more with him. We've
seen exactly the same thing happening
here. Exactly the same thing.
John 6 verse 67. Then said Jesus unto
the twel,
will he also go away?
And what did they answer?
Then Simon Peter answered him, Lord, to
whom shall we go? Thou hast the words of
eternal life.
If there is only one truth and that
truth is the the way and the truth and
the life and it leads to Christ and
Christ leads us to obedience then there
is no other way. So when we are faced
with a decision am I going to do this am
I not going to do this if I want to have
life and I know what's right and I do it
not then it become for me what says the
Bible sin. So I have to make a decision.
Some will say
there are many things I do not
understand yet. There's too much that I
don't understand. I cannot make a
decision. I don't understand many
things. How long would you be able to
put it off this way?
Probably forever. I don't understand
everything. I certainly don't. And I
presume that I will be learning for the
rest of my existence, even throughout
eternal life.
Let's see what the Bible says on this
issue. Psalms 97:11,
"Light is sown for the righteous and
gladness for the upright in heart."
I believe that everybody sitting here
today,
we've been together through this whole
series. We have done so much together
and still you are sitting here. So I
know that you you enjoyed this light.
Maybe it wasn't easy, but you listened.
Psalms 112:4, "Unto the upright there
arises light in the darkness." Start
understanding how it all fits together.
There are so many questions. Why this?
Why that? Why is this one like that? Why
is that one the other way? How can we
all belong to the same thing? How is one
saved? All these questions. If you
really are upright in heart, God gives
you the answer.
Psalms 119 verse 130, the entrance of
thy words gives light. So if it's not
wordbased, if it's not biblical, then
that light is not necessarily from God.
Proverbs 4:18, "The path of the
righteous is like the first glimpse of
dawn, shining ever brighter till the
full light of day." So will it get
brighter and brighter and brighter as
one goes on? Yes or no? Yes. You can
never get to the point where where you
can say, "I understand it all.
Otherwise, you can put it away." You
know, I have discovered one thing. I can
take a novel. I can take a science book.
I'm a I'm a professor in physiology.
There's a physiology book that I used
for a long time. I don't even have to
bother to pick it up anymore.
I can go to my class and I can preach it
off by heart. Just leave it there. I
never have to look in it again. The book
doesn't change. It's exactly the same
yesterday, today, and tomorrow. New
stuff. Yes, that you have to keep up the
day. Remember that book? I don't have to
bother about it. But the Bible,
I've been studying that now for 16 years
and I still am over aed by what I read
in the verse that I thought I knew every
single day. You will learn forever and
ever. So this this reason for not
following Christ in fullness is one that
you will never overcome except by taking
a step of faith. None of the priests and
the rulers believed. This is a very
important question.
If this is truth,
how many lectures have we had together?
I forget. Whatever it was, 30. I don't
know. And every single one of them, did
it sound like the truth to you? Yes or
no?
>> Can I see some hands? Who says it
sounded like the truth? I can see a
couple of hands. Now, if this sounded
like the truth,
and if this is the truth,
then where are all the big guns? Why are
they not here? Where are all the others?
Where are all the theologians
and the priests and the pastors and the
this and the that? Why aren't they all
rushing to this? If this is truth,
well, nothing's ever changed. In the
past, they also didn't do it. John 7:32,
the chief priests sent officers to
arrest him. They didn't even bother to
go and listen to himself. They just sent
someone. Go and get rid of that guy. He
is irritating.
Do you know what's nice about the faith
that
I stand for? He said, "I don't have to
hide it."
>> Amen.
>> I can go into a public venue. I can book
the biggest hall in the world and I can
stand there and I can preach it and
nobody will be able to say it's not so
because I never said a word.
>> I just put one quote after the other on
the screen. Isn't that right? Isn't that
what we did?
>> So what would they do if they came and
said don't listen to him?
What if Rome came to condemn me and
said, "How dare this man say these
things and they arrest me for saying
these things?" All I will say is, "I
never said a word. They said it
themselves. Go and arrest them."
>> They said it. Go and arrest them.
So this faith is not something that is
grabbed out of the air. It's based on
the biblical foundation. And I can
defend it anywhere. I don't have to go
knocking like a thief on a back door and
slip you a pamphlet to coersse you into
this that or the other. Didn't force you
to be here. You're all sitting here by
your own free choice listening and
checking verse for verse going back.
I've got a letter there of a a person
there who went back to the to the to the
web to see is this really so I love that
this dark day question. Looked up that
date. Wow. There it says, "Dark Day, New
England to this day, unexplained." And
they bring it to me. They say, "Yes,
being confirmed." Every single word.
Every single word. The chief priests,
they sent officers to go and arrest him.
Verse 46, they came back and they said
to the priests, "Sorry," they said,
"Where's he? We sent you to arrest him."
And they said, "But you know, no one
ever spoke like this man.
Nobody ever gave them so much to think
about
as Jesus did." Verse 47. You mean he has
deceived you also?
Has any of the rulers and the Pharisees
believed him? Well, we're in much the
same boat. Fortunately,
even in biblical times, many of the
Pharisees and the scribes did believe.
Most of them didn't, but many of them
did. Nicodemus did. Even though he came
in the middle of the night scared that
he might be seen, he believed. And he
was a powerhouse after that. I tell you
that thousands
and thousands are accepting this truth.
Thousands. There are millions across the
globe that are accepting this truth. And
they're being added to every single day.
Thousands upon thousands upon thousands
in South America every day. Two, three
thousand are being added every single
day. Now you just add that up over time.
Millions are coming into this truth. If
they do surveys
and they find out how many seventh day
Adventists are there, then you will find
that on the on the surveys there are
more Seventh Day Adventists than in the
books of the church. That's fascinating.
If a government does a survey in its
country asking what denomination do you
believe belong to, there are more
seventh day Adventists in that country
than on the books of the church. What
does that tell you?
>> That in their hearts they've accepted
this truth, but they haven't made the
final step yet. There are whole
churches, including the pastor, whole
churches that are coming over to this
truth. Why?
Because there's so much to it, you
cannot gain it. And others will say, you
mean he has deceived you also? None of
the others have believed him. But maybe
they haven't bothered to study it. Some
will say the price is too high. I don't
want to pay this price. I have to give
up too much. What is it to give up? My
father, if it is possible, may this cup
be taken from me. Yet not my will, but
as you will. It's it's profound that God
should choose something as simple
as obedience a day to make a difference
between right and wrong. Absolutely
amazing. I'll wait till the spirit moves
me.
You know, I really know this is right,
but you know, I really don't want to
move yet. Isn't that another one that
people use?
Well, Proverbs 16:25 says, "There's a
way that seems right to a man, but in
the end it leads to death." If you know
something is right, then do it. I'm not
one of those evangelists who will stand
up here and pressurize you because all
these times we have spoken to your minds
and hopefully to your hearts as well.
But I certainly would like to have your
heart and your mind working together.
This is your choice, not mine. I don't
have to force you. You decide. Is this
right or is this wrong? Maybe you really
do believe that. You don't know yet.
You're not certain. That's fair enough.
Then you say, "But I either want to
learn more about this because I think
this is right or I want nothing else to
do with it. That's also your decision.
No one else's.
It'll cause division.
I know that if I accept this, my husband
or my wife, they're going to freak.
I might lose my boyfriend or my
girlfriend, my job, my family is going
to go nuts.
Mine did.
My cousin
did this across the table.
He says, "That's your half and this is
my half. I'll never put my foot in your
house again. We were best friends. We
were always together. We ate together.
We drank together. We laughed together.
We cried together.
He hasn't been in my house in 16 years.
It's tough.
My family,
some of them actually know it's the
truth,
but won't move. It's amazing. Amazing.
and others whole families just accept
it. I cannot understand it. It drives me
nuts. I'm so jealous.
Whole family, father, mother, uncle,
boyfriend, girlfriend. I gave Bible
studies in my home to a group of people
and uh the one girl was going out with
one of with my son. My son brought her
to the Bible study. So, she started
listening to the Bible study. Next thing
she brought her sister. They were
Methodists. Brought her sister. Next
thing they brought the father. Next
thing they brought the mother. Next
thing they brought the other boyfriends
and the other every single one. No
problem.
>> Unbelievable. Sometimes it works like
that. You don't know. But it can
certainly cause division. Matthew
10:34-37.
Think not. I'm come to send peace on the
earth. I came not to send peace, but a
sword. The word is going to be the
sword. And that's going to be the only
weapon that we have.
For I am come to set a man at variance
against his father, and the daughter
against her mother, and the
daughter-in-law against her
mother-in-law, and a man's foes shall be
they of his own household. He that
loveth father or mother more than me is
not worthy of me. And he that loveth son
or daughter more than me is not worthy
of me. Do you know what? The Bible has
every base covered. There's no way to
move out of this one except decide.
He that does not take his cross and
follow after me is not worthy of me.
Now that entails a cross. That means
it's a burden. You have to pick it up
and you have to follow Christ. That
doesn't mean we are wretched, miserable
individuals, but it does take a cross.
It is a burden. And you know what the
greatest burden is? Your greatest burden
does not become yourself anymore. Your
greatest burden is how many of you felt
this?
How am I going to convince my mother,
father, husband, wife,
boyfriend, girlfriend? How many of you
felt this? Can I see some hands?
I can see some hands. This is the
burden. The burden is just like Christ
had a burden for souls. My wife sat down
and cried when she heard these messages
for the first time. Not for herself, but
for her parents,
her father. She loved her father. He was
such a nice man. He's dead now. so kind,
so generous. He was such fun to have
around.
And he was a newager, probably a
highmason, an occultist,
and he worshiped the devil.
>> Wow, that's pretty scary.
I don't know what happened to him in the
end. We took care of him until he died
or my wife did. And uh he never ever
said one negative word towards the end
anymore. And what went on in his mind is
between God and him. I wish I hope I
believe I will see him at the
resurrection.
But everyone has a cross and we have to
follow him. But now thus says the Lord
that created thee, oh Jacob, and he that
formed thee, oh Israel, fear not for I
have redeemed thee. I have called thee
by thy name. Thou art mine.
>> Isaiah 43:E1.
Do you think God will leave you alone
with that cross?
>> No.
>> To carry it alone?
There it says, "I've created you and I
formed you and there's nothing to be
afraid of."
He is the one who says fear not. Those
are the issues. That's what we've
discussed all this time. Oh, there's
lots more. We haven't even started yet.
Have we had a Daniel seminar? No. We've
touched here and there on Daniel. Have
we had a Revelation seminar? No, we've
touched here and there on Revelation.
Why do I talk about those two books?
Because they particularly concern our
time, the end of time. We haven't
touched Isaiah, which is the whole
Bible, in one prophetic word. My
favorite book, Isaiah. Wow. Such comfort
in that book. We haven't read the Psalms
together to discern what all the Psalms,
some of them are esqueological, some are
messianic, some are just comfort. Some
are what it means to be repenting. We
haven't read the Torah together. We've
done nothing. We've gained through the
precepts and the principles. There's so
much more to learn and we're going to
continue with this. Even though I'm
going to leave and I'm going to be gone,
it's not me that you're interested in.
You're interested in Jesus Christ. He's
all that matters.
>> And when you come into a body, that's
who you serve. You serve Jesus Christ.
You don't look around and say, "Now, why
is this one like that? Why this one not
doing what is right?" It's not your
business whether he's doing right or
whether he's not doing right. Your
business is to follow Christ.
and to follow his precepts.
And we must come into harmony. That
means I can go to my brother and say,
"Listen, brother, why are you still
doing this when the Bible actually says
this and that and the other in love?"
You can do that. There's nothing wrong
with that. Don't expect perfection, but
expect truth.
>> And don't give up until you found all of
it. That's what it's all about. And
follow Christ, and he he will help you.
Fear not. He has redeemed you. So that
is the issue. Not that we finished, but
we've come to a point where we can make
a decision. So I would like to invite
anyone who has decided
or has come to the conclusion that this
is truth
to stay behind afterwards so that we can
discuss how do we continue? Where do we
go from here? How do I fulfill the right
of baptism? Or I have been baptized
already or I'm not ready yet. What do I
do? Where do I get nurtured further?
What do I do? Can't just run away from
the body of Christ. They were added
daily. So, I would like to invite
everyone that was convicted that we've
heard truth up until now to stay behind
when we end now and let's talk briefly,
just briefly together as to what are we
going to do on the way forward. Some of
you might feel you're ready for baptism.
Some might feel I want to join the body.
Some might feel otherwise. Let's do that
after this meeting. No pressure, nothing
like that. Just your decision. Let us
pray. Heavenly Father,
thank you Lord for truth. Thank you for
a word that is truth from the first page
to the last. And thank you for the
example that you have set us in Jesus
Christ. Help us to keep our eyes fixed
upon you and to follow you in all
obedience.
Lord,
please
come into our hearts and into our minds
and help us to make right decisions
so that we will follow you wheresoever
you lead and not where man intends to
lead any one of us. Thank you for all
the people that are here tonight and
thank you Lord that you are speaking to
every single one of us. Lord, there are
many that have known this truth for
years, myself included. And I would also
tonight together with them
like to recommmit my life to you
>> and say Lord I might have slipped along
the pathway. I might have made mistakes
but I know Lord that by your grace the
righteous man falls many times but you
raise him up again. So those who want to
recommmit their lives to you may they
also make a decision tonight in Jesus
name. Amen. Amen.
Number
hey.
Oh,
glory.
oh,
oh.
Oh,
thank you.
go
oh.